no maid waters that be our path I was
Industrial Light magics visual effects
supervisor on Pirates of the Caribbean
the mo major was probably the biggest
part of our work on the film one of the
big challenges for us was to explore how
creature light to make them and how
predatory versus how much they would be
like the actresses that performed them
the mermaids we're gonna have to sort of
strike a balance between extremely
beautiful you know this seductive
beautiful siren and very monstrous and
creature II and vicious you know because
there was gonna be a whole attack scene
where they you know dragged the sailors
to their death we actually went down the
path of making them quite scary
they had very extreme sort of texture
like very a lot of prominent scales sort
of the patterning that you would find on
some of the more dangerous sea predators
we played with very silvery skin so that
you'd have little accents and little
Glen's so they seemed a little bit more
creepy they'll be mermaids upon us
within the hour you mark my words when
the film is more assembled in any more
of a finished form you know Rob took the
step back and looked at it and said you
know what I really love the actresses
and I really want to see them in the
mermaids it was kind of an interesting
thing because we had to really turn the
whole production around and what's
dangerous about that is suddenly you're
veering towards the uncanny valley the
idea that as something looks more human
it becomes a lot harder to achieve
something that people will believe we
used facial motion capture we used all
of our skin shading technology we
developed over the years and it was
quite a big change a big challenge and
we worked around the clock basically to
pull it off we shot in the mermaid Cove
for probably a month
shooting nights at the same time had a
modeler and a painter and a team here
creating the digital versions of the
mermaid we started off thinking okay
there's like 11 or 12 mermaids that come
and take these pirates and then Rob's
like no no there's 50 mermaids that take
them so you have to deal with whole
crowds of mermaids and adding splashes
to all of those so we came up with a lot
of automatic tools we used some of our
best water simulation technology and
then shot a bunch of
elements of people in black suits
splashing around in you know wading
pools it's hard work and it really some
of the water simulation stuff is just it
blows your mind there's a whole lot of
math you have to really understand fluid
dynamics we have some very clever people
who are experts in that and it was
really hard for them luckily we also
have a bunch of really talented
compositors who are able to combine all
these elements and make them really sit
together in the scene you have to be
able to simulate something so it looks
physically real but then you have to be
able to out directed as well and make it
do what you want it to do
trying to capture something like that is
tremendously challenging and you need to
use every trick in the book